o desvio dos muitos animais é o melhor
ou o estrago de que tinha muitas e
muitas vezes
caso o treinamento vamos jogar muitas
bolinhas de dólares 22 mesmo então
técnicas podem fazer nós vamos testar
cento não têm padrinhos 50 para mim e 50
para o caso e portanto nesse meu vídeo
evolutivo de 50 euros em rebanhos e o
caso vai abrir outros 50 euros no canal
del estado para el apoyo e vai jogar
pensei - prêmio vai cumprir um desafio
que é faltar na piscina
é muita
tinha muita e nós viemos aqui fazer um
espírito muito pessoal agora é daqui
fazer este espírito que inclusive lucas
neto eu espero muito que saiu prêmio
porque nós que estamos senhoras que
ganhou foi rodrigo pimpão não pode
perder meu mestre do lápis nós que não
chegarão mais neste vídeo ao lado das
relíquias eu vou ganhar um milhão de
euros
portanto não não acho que não é só com
um milagre eu vou ficar pobre com as
pessoas podendo agora lá do dentista é o
nosso caso
aqui então essas podem como funciona
então esta é o ponto de ouro basicamente
tem um prêmio e tem aqui um dólar o euro
o euro
[Música]
agora já sabem será que algum deles vem
o prêmio siqueira campos lá 11 certo e
11 anos
imaginem só com 10 eu ganharia senhor na
zona euro o valor pode ser que este
prémio é de 10 mil euros tanto ganhar 10
mil mais uma vez em 1989 onze nunca em
nada meu som premium prêmio novos 29
muito novo
o prêmio 22 10 numa só
certo só que em 321 vai o meu gosto
muito dos seis e onze embora prêmio
2 a 1 euro para 1 14 21 21 19 e 15 10
a nova linha mais um novo mas outro 11
meu deus não sai como é que é possível a
raspadinha 93
[Música]
agora vai ter um design embora 31 vai já
na primeira
a 12 9 mil swaps vai ser importante lá
quiaca chamado 10 por aí
o o gol mas vez mais mas vai ser uma boa
mãe joy pessoal e 15 horas mas não tem
poder não faz nenhuma nessa hora 31
bairro mil euros destas 321 vai de 1º a
21 vai
como assim
a idéia aqui é de 7 9 11 e 18 13 9
a 81 em 16 11 a 14 8 a 10
o primeiro é só agora 32 um pai um euro
a amã bosta destas 321 bairro um euro
mais caro viajar ou 12 um euro o meu 15
15 anos ainda como é que tem dez
ai ai ai ai
dos oito filha da mãe nem poderá ter
mais uma boa mãe e da irmã mas só vai
com mais de 3.000 e 5.000 m em breve
a qualquer prêmio seja aí acima de 1
euro o deputado vai vai
mãe mas agora com mais uma bola
a mesma idéia de viver qualquer prémio
que saiu de mim mas toma lá 8 11 ae nova
e que não foi dele o tento sexta 11 13
eu não sei o que é ficar pobre 1192
vamos tentar reparar o contrário ou seja
vamos respeitar o prêmio e depois vamos
ver qual é que saiu 10 não aceitamos
esse prêmio sae 1.500 20 senhoras ok eu
não quero o meu e 500 só quero o sangue
caiu de cima define que um sem ok 1.500
22 11 a 10
a última tinha algo especial vamos
raspar a última esposa na sanita agora
presente em toda nova
18 jan lusa o caso já morreu ou não só
continuar no chão muito comigo aiaiai
que tal prêmio 15 certo nojo dele
contagem hoje 5 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 18 18
11 no canal do caso e também dão conta
que vai ganhar em 2011 fiquem bem até a
próxima